who do you think the audiences for day
out of days wow I don't want to just be
like the woman director who makes movies
for women I mean I will be but I mean I
think that there's I mean I go to see
movies about men all the time so I don't
see why men shouldn't go see movie about
a woman who's struggling or you know
there's men in the movie if they're
really bored by it but I read I just
think that the audience should be I
don't I got an email from a friend of
mine who's a young actress and she was
talking about the movie and she said it
affected her the idea affected her so
much because it was what she might
become and I hadn't even thought about
that I was so in the moment with this
40-year old actress that I hadn't
thought about I mean of course the
elders they all know what was what had
come but the the ones had not had seen
the future and I never thought about
that kind of audience so I thought that
was really interesting to see a younger
people projecting on to what might be
able what might become of them so you
know I I'm hoping for anyone who likes
you know movies to go check it out and
god I hope it's good yeah it's a funny
thing about youth we look at people that
are older than us and think that they
were just always like that we don't
realize that they were one you know that
someone had said that to me a long time
ago because you just don't envision that
they were once your age as well they
were just always it's shocking it's
almost more shocking to look at older
people and realized that they were once
your age then look at someone who's
younger and then you will become me you
know but no it's true and it's it's you
know we have to accept this I mean
there's such a Chisum problems in the
world I don't want to see the movie
about old people you know and you know
but there there's a vitality that I
guess as you get older you realize you
will carry that vitality through your
entire life and whether you're you know
40 or 80 you still have that weird guy
talked to people all the time or like I
feel like I'm 19 or I'm I have a friend
who's 83 and she said hi
to be 60 again I was like oh ok ok some
perspective in it so you know you just
have to enjoy your life and make the
things that you want you know
you